if you like me spend a lot of time
playing games then you've probably had
this thought cross your mind before what
if your life was a video game just like
in a game you could level up your skills
and see your progress back you could
customize the way that you look at the
push of a button and you could easily
see how well your conversation of choice
was impressing your crush I mean think
about it if your life was a game it
would be one big adventure you would get
all some missions to accomplish like
slaying dragons or obtaining new magical
powers or more realistically you'd be
bombarded by a side quest but finally
don't get in the way but the more I
think about this the more I realized
that growing up in this digitally driven
generation life kind of is a game or at
least it's becoming more game aside now
hear me out of course it's not a game in
the sense that we're going out and
slaying dragons and getting magic powers
I freaking wish but just like in a game
we seem to have certain stats that we
can perceivably level up through knots
our actual selves but our digital cells
when you have an Xbox or Playstation or
even if you play on games like Skyrim
Wow
below or you make an avatar right you
make them look how you want them to look
you make them have certain skills and
the tributes that you feel kind of
relate to you probably or are completely
the opposite to you you want to make
something completely different and in
real life we sort of do that - we have
our real selves the cells that aren't
always that great and have breakdowns
and we pick our noses I know you do
don't tell me that you don't but then we
have our digital cells that we share
online for the whole entire world see
and that self is the one that is more
gamified just like any game
we're able to give ourselves stats on
our digital selves throughout these
digital platforms these websites so
these social media accounts and there
are so many in a way gamification can be
amazing gamifying your life means that
you get goals to reach you can see how
far you're progressing it makes you very
motivated and a lot of education systems
have actually grasped onto this places
like code Academy and things like that
where their game afire learning I think
is awesome it's an awesome way to learn
you can see the or getting awards you're
learning you're progressing in your
skill set and it makes you feel so so
good but in so many other ways this
gamification of our digital selves can
be kind of scary if we don't pay
attention to it and realize what it
could be doing to our real selves that
are hiding behind the digital self that
it's online this by the way it's my
digital self hi nice to meet you mmm-hmm
we're in that age now we're checking the
internet checking our phones having it
buzz constantly but notifications is is
the norm it's constantly kind of a
recognition of who you are who you're
putting out there online and what are
the people are thinking of you but if
you think about it logically and you
think about it in a gaming sense it's
basically just numbers if you upload a
new photo to Instagram you're gonna get
a certain amount of Hearts if you upload
a new profile picture to Facebook you
may get some love likes or some hats
hopefully not the Hat has why people
laughing your profile pitch unless it's
supposed to be funny and also people are
using these platforms in amazing ways
they're documenting how they are
progressing as people they're
documenting their journeys through life
if they're musicians they're putting
their music online if they bake or do
art they're posting their arts and their
tree everything that they're doing
online so people can see how they
progress and this is amazing because as
the person who's putting their outputs
onto these platforms you're seeing how
it's being perceived by a wider audience
and with these numbers of people like
income
shirring hopefully you're seeing a
progression of these numbers you're
seeing it slowly go upwards as your
skills progress the numbers progress as
well and in a way that's telling you
that you're winning you're leveling up
you are reaching higher levels and it's
making you more determined to do what
you're doing just like in a game when
you're leveling up fast or you've had a
really tough time getting past a certain
level and then you make it it makes you
want to play the game more and makes you
more motivated makes you more excited
makes you happy but there are so many
ways where this can suddenly crumble
this can become your downfall
the gamification of social media can be
a terrifying terrifying concept because
unlike a game when things go wrong when
people don't like what you do when you
feel like you're not good enough because
the numbers aren't matching up or
they're dropping and you're leveling
down instead of up you can't just simply
rage quit you cannot just shock your
controller and saying that I'm done
because the digital you it's still you
you're giving what you perceive as the
best parts of yourself and you're
putting them online this isn't a
fictional character that you've just
made up a green bumpy skin who looks
like a troll because that was funny at
the time
I liked her green zombie skin do you
call that troll Villa boring but anyway
the point is people online can see you
as I guess an avatar because they don't
know the real you they're just seeing
this one version of you that you're
putting out there under filters and
under precise text and everything else
and they don't get to see the real you
or the real impact that they might have
on what they say to you or if they don't
like your photo this is this is weird
I'm making something I am so sure that
life is just becoming more and more
gamified and this can be really good but
it can be very very very detrimental to
your mental health if you don't switch
off just like you switch off a game you
want to be plugged into the game
forever maybe you do but you shouldn't
do because real life is there too and
you need to step outside but at the same
time we need to step away from the
gamification of life that has brought to
us through the internet and social media
because it can get so crazy there is no
off button when you spend forever
choosing a new facebook profile picture
when you spend so long learning a new
song or drawing new pace why can't they
pace a new piece of art you feel like
these numbers and these stats are
decreasing and you're leveling down and
you're not getting any better this is
not game you can't just switch off you
can't just blame the controller you're
basically grading yourself with you're
basing these numbers that has shown to
you online throughout all these social
media platforms and way that the
Internet is you're telling yourself this
is how good I am
is this how my sigh look this is how
talented I am this is how intelligent I
am because in the game it's so simple
they're just stats that's just bars your
friends at level 10 you're at level 8
you know you can just spend a whole day
playing the game and you will win them
in the next bell that you play against
them but in life if you take this to
heart and your digital self becomes a
reflection on the real you and who you
are and you take everything very
literally and very personally this
really play with your mental health I
think it's something to be aware of when
it becomes more personal and it's about
the way that you look or the way that
you act or the skills that you have or
what you're proud of who you are as a
person your self-worth you need to
differentiate from the Internet you and
the real you because those figures don't
matter they should not define who you
are in the real world because the real
you is worth so much more than a bunch
of love heart likes or numbers I'm not
too sure how to end this I was just
thinking about life being a game and how
amazing that would be and then I kind of
realize
but every now and then I do get quite
down because life is a game and I know
that if I've spent a long time on
something and I'm really proud of it
soon as I've realized that other people
might not think so or it's not being
perceived in the way that I thought it
would
I will instantly put myself down even if
before I put it up there as my digital
self I was happy with it
and that's something that perhaps I have
a mindset of because I play games and
because I'm so used to the leveling up
system or maybe it's something that you
can relate to and if you can then I want
you to become aware of it because I
wasn't aware of it for a very long time
and I think now that I am aware of it I
know how to deal with it a lot better
I know that I need to shut off from the
incident sometimes I need to shut down
my game of life and enjoy real life go
out to see nature do things with my
friends do things for me on my own
without sharing it online without trying
to give myself another level up by
getting some extra lights on a new
Instagram post or something like that
don't get me wrong you guys know that I
love the internet I love social media I
am on there all the time but once it
starts to become personal I just think
you need to shut down the game that's
them don't hug me I'm scared isn't it
it's my digits on me anyway I'm getting
distracted I just want to say a massive
thank you to 1nt for sponsoring this
video it's people like them that really
really helped me to keep doing what I'm
doing I'm making content for you guys I
love working with people because they
give me creative briefs and then I get
to be as creative as I like with and not
to mention their game revenge of sultans
is actually pretty addictive I've been
playing it for quite a while now every
single day it's a massive multiplayer
online game join people around the world
in this epic RTS Emma
to reclaim the kingdom of Arabian
Peninsula yeah basically you are a lord
and you have your own Kingdom and you
have to manage that by upgrading your
troops and building and did you get a
horse as well once you get to level 4 I
think it was well it's pretty excited
when I'm so close to them realize you
get that so you can upgrade your horse
as well and of course you got your walls
and your castle and you've got little
other parts that you can unlock along
the way and you you're constantly
getting money as well I'm usually in
these things you have to pay to kind of
carry on playing and you can do that in
this game I'm not gonna lie to you but
you just keep on getting little packages
of things like every single day so I
haven't had to tell you anything which
is great and then even better you get to
go off from your kingdom and explore
what is around you so you get to go to
other kingdoms you get to charge and try
to take over them I have been taking
over a couple of times that I'm really
bad keep on failing I'm really at this
gay but it's okay because I'm not
failing at the game of life but yeah you
get to send your troops out and then you
can battle creatures like genies or
goats that will give you experience
points you will have a better chance to
actually take over someone else's
Kingdom they've got a pretty cool
community around it as well so you can
make your own alliances once you get to
level 6 and then you can have all your
friends kind of in a comment board and
you can play together which is really
nice because it's always good to have
that kind of competitive element but
also the element where you can just play
and share your progress and everything
cool that you've been doing with your
friends anyway the link for that game
will be in the description below so do
check that out if you want to play a new
game on your mobile
it's a row for iPhone and Android so
everyone can play and it's free to play
so that's even better so thank you again
1mt for this brilliant opportunity to
work with you and for introducing me to
your pretty fun game anyway if this
video sparked some sort of realization
in your
that actually hey my life could be a
video game as well because of social
media or if you think that I'm just
talking absolute bollocks then do write
in the comments below I'd love to start
a conversation about this and see what
your thoughts are on the topic I'm
probably gonna get some comments like oh
you're overthinking because I get that a
lot
so I'm probably just overthinking but
hey ho it's pretty cool to think of life
as a game though right
it keeps you competitive it keeps you
wanting to level up just don't let it
get too far that's that's all I'm trying
to say just don't let it get too far
life is still life life is no game but
it can be fun okay time to shut down now
digital me plugged out have a lovely
evening bye
okay I just rambled like so much there
I'm so sorry yes like this is gonna be
the hardest thing to edit